dc comics has confirmed that superman is
officially a little light in the loafers
i myself had always had my suspicions
the tights the chiseled body the lack if
we're honest of any real sexual tension
with lois lane but the creatives have
now dispelled any doubts the new
superman much like our entire culture is
super
duper gay superman
is pretty
and witty and now
he is gay
uh i do not follow the superhero stuff
all that closely you know i i never
really read comic books as a kid and i
certainly don't read them now but
according to dc comics
john kent who is
the new superman he's the the son of
clark kent and lois lane the original
superman and his beard
john kent is apparently bisexual this is
a very important plot point of course
for the man of steel
uh
he also in this new comic will have a
love scene with a dude and the dude has
pinkish purple hair and looks a bit
bit on the young side uh and they they
have a gay kiss but he's not he's not
totally gay he's just like a little bit
gay
and it just seems to me
well i had the same reaction that blake
masters did blake masters is a
republican senate candidate in arizona
he saw the news and i don't know if he's
a comic book fan or anything but he just
he retweeted it and he said
not
everything has to be gay
there's no no offense to
people with unusual sexual desires or
behaviors or anything like that but
why does everything why is everything
gay
you know especially when june rolls
around june in our liberal liturgical
calendar is is pride month and for the
month of june at least in the west not
you'll notice not in the middle east or
some other places but in the west every
corporation every institution every
non-profit every person becomes gay for
exactly 30 days and then it stops and
you just think well
why
why is that we'll get to more of that in
just one second first though i have had
the privilege of staying at nice hotels
this is the only silver lining to having
to be on the road and away from my
beautiful wife and young baby
is occasionally they'll they'll take me
out of the flea bags they'll put me up
at a nice hotel and the first thing you
notice is the quality of the bedding the
quality of the sheets and i didn't i
didn't know this
for my bachelor dump but
you can get the luxury five-star quality
bedding that you get at a top hotel you
can get that every single night in your
home and you can do that with bowl and
branch bowl and branch has these
incredible sheets signature hem sheets
100 organic cotton they start out soft
they get softer and softer and nicer and
nicer over time they've got a wonderful
sateen weave there's no middleman
between you and bowling branch so you
get luxury quality for the fairest price
30 night worry free guarantee but you're
going to love it so you're not going to
worry about that 30 39 guarantee to
experience an entirely new standard of
comfort visit bowlingbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets with promo
code michael that's b-o-l-l and branch
dot com promo code michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l so blake masters says not
everything needs to be gay but in a way
everything sort of does need to be gay
because
if you're going to
in insist upon this new moral standard
it's not going to stop
at
do whatever you do you you do you i'll
do me
you follow your lights but don't impose
your views on anyone that's kind of the
the
libertarian-ish approach someone said
libertine approach to moral philosophy
but
it it doesn't really stop there because
and every single society has to have
some
vision of what it considers to be the
good it's got to have some standard this
is the thesis of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds and
so as standards start to change they're
going to change for all of society and
every i don't mean to call out just the
lgbt issue here but this is true of any
sort of standard it is going to pervade
the society and if you think that you
can just compartmentalize it and put it
in one corner of society you can't
you're trying for something that that
never has been and never will be i'm so
glad you liked that clip if you don't
mind
leave me a comment say you like the clip
that's very sweet of you
uh subscribe and ring the bell and head
on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael noel
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you